also achtung nicht parat ja ich will das
glas das ist doch ein schöner klang
frohe weihnachten frohe weihnachten auf
uns zum wohl auf ronny wir haben ja
englische weihnacht deswegen gibt es
immer am 25
turkey immer wir feiern um 24 uhr
zwanzigsten bin ich auf der kleine
komikerin wenn leute von mir bücher
kriegen haben sie immer das gefühl die
habe ich sowieso dreimal geschickt
bekommen und hier immer diese karriere
gartens zu hören dass es dort verpacken
mit aufkleber zum gehst mit den verlagen
zu planen ein paar tische oder
buchhandel
ich verschenke dann muss ich hier immer
vor sichtbar geschenken von nikolaus
schneider sage ich nur falls man bücher
verschenken möchte hätte ich hier ein
paar anregungen er macht ja lieber
allein als gar keine freunde
dieses buch geht darum dass die
gesellschaft ist stigmatisiert wenn man
allein ist das würde ich dem menschen
empfehlen die einen sinn für humor haben
unbedingt also eigentlich wäre es super
für dich geeignet hier bitte ich
empfehle ein klassiker wie der schnee
war schmutzig von georges simenon wenn
roman über einen jungen mann dessen
mutter ist bordellbesitzerin in einer
kleinen stadt die vom militär besetzt
ist und er will hoch hinaus und was
passiert er rutscht total rein in die
kriminalität
zeitgleich hat sich aber die
nachbarstochter city in ihn verliebt es
hat zum teil fast etwas kitschig ist
aber es ist gefüllt hier bekanntlich
manchmal und jetzt hast du mich noch
angespannt auch mein gott die zielgruppe
sind alle die klassiker mögen und
gleichzeitig dieses historisch
angehauchte von georges simenon schätzen
ich liebe ja weihnachten denn ich habe
mich jetzt meine schönste fest um das
nicht also ich finde mein geburtstag ist
auch schön mein geburtstag ja auch ganz
uneigennützigen ja ich weiß gibt so
viele leute die immer sagen so hat mein
geburtstag ist mir ganz egal und so wie
überhaupt nicht ich gebe ein großes ist
mir egal ich ja ich weiß nicht ob du
berlin babylon schaust und ja
dann wäre das in der tat was für dich
vicki baum ist dieser interessante fall
einer vergessenen bestseller-autor
berlin babylon späten 20er jahre die
rollenmuster brechen auf die mode ändert
sich dieses buch finde ich eben als
attraktive aufgemacht und dann weiß ich
ja wunderschöne zwanziger jahren die
gesellschaft so ungeheuer modernen war
und dann denke ich mir immer meine güte
was ist denn da alles noch passiert dass
wir so zurückgeblieben sind also der
darlehen wie brüchig die modernität ist
auf der wir uns heute bewegen
michael ondaatje also unterschied hätte
jeder vom englischen patienten der da
verfilmt wurde und mehrere oscars
bekommen hat kriegt das ist jetzt sein
aktueller roman der hat mich wirklich
extrem angesprochen das ist wirklich ein
buch für alle die romane mögen
familiengeschichten und auch so dieses
element von trügerischen erinnerungen
dass man immer wieder sachen entdeckt
die eigentlich ganz anders waren als es
im grunde genommen schien ich meine das
liest sich einfach rasant durch so ein
schönes weihnachtsgeschenk
ich wünsche dir auch ein glückliches
weihnachtsfest zu hause liegt der schnee
es ist wahnsinnig kalt die fenster hier
sind beschlagen der kamin schlackert auf
wiedersehen bis zum nächsten jahr
[Musik]